what's the greatest
science fiction book ever written
just
removing your
uh
work from consideration
uh
i'm loving torturing you greatest ever
non stevenson do we include fantasy
does to have to be science fiction
oh interesting fantasy
hmm
i did not expect that twist uh well in
for in a weird way they're lumped
together in people's minds right so
they are but it they're but there's also
a boundary somehow yeah i'm not sure
what that is exactly nobody is it's a
mystery
so i mean if we do include it then it's
easily the the lord of the rings
but
i mean
greatness is a interesting quality to uh
to try to define
um
and
for me a lot of the the fun and the joy
of
such books is is not in what you'd call
greatness but just storytelling
so i was always a big fan of has have
space suit will travel
which is a heinlein young adult book
it's just uh it's just a fun good read
um
so it's a fun is a big component
greatness is overrated well i don't know
it's overrated but it's just you know
it's it might be under defined let's put
it that way
so have space it will travel now i
definitely have to read that one
you